[Music]
my name is Artur meet Tomac we'll talk
about hyper parameters in predictive
modeling and let's start from the
beginning what are hyper parameters for
you could you give an example these are
parameters hyper parameters control
usually control complexity of models for
example depth of three number of neurons
in the neural network and this is the
most obvious approach the first bullet
less obvious hyper parameter is a method
of feature selection for example number
of best features from some filter method
from for example a variable importance
ranking to be taken to build a model and
least obvious our hyper parameters
related for example to preparation of
the data set to perform pca don't
perform pca perform scaling or what's
horizon for historical data to aggregate
should we take data from the last year
or to last year's usually it's not
optimized directly but treating it as a
hyper parameter all all these parameters
as hyper parameters and using suitable
methods we can optimize much more and
deliver much better predictive models so
this is subject of our presentation the
standard approach is to tune hyper
parameters that control complexity of
model exactly as I told number of trees
in XD boost number of trees in random
forests death of a tree number of leaves
and what's important what we are atomic
will talk about can be applied not only
to
predictive models but to every
complicated blackbox optimization there
are very different analytical tasks
let's say analytic set of many speeds
the first one a real-time or near
real-time zero to five minutes to build
a model I will go through this examples
later the second one under one hour
several hours and up to 16 hours and
usually computation time doesn't depend
on the type of the model it depends on
strategy of estimation of hyper
parameters this is time consuming and
for each of these approaches we can use
a slightly different approach to
estimation of hyper parameters let's go
through three cases assume that we are
an analyst in debt collection agency you
know what I mean a company that buys
some bad loans and tries to recover some
money the process looks like this they
have a proposal to buy number of such
loans they they have a data set with a
number of columns with characteristics
of these loans and they need to give
price for this package basing on these
predictors so what they usually do is to
find sorry not not this way what this
analyst should do is to prepare pricing
and recommendation what what's the
optimal price we should pay this price
should be low enough to be the best one
to win this package to buy this package
and it must be high enough and low low
enough to get some money back from this
package and to earn enough so what is
usually done so called a reference
population is taken there are taken from
our historical historical data some
loans
as similar as possible to our our sample
and we built a classification model or
our a regression model and usually these
analysts play a lot with reference
populations so they need to build models
in the real time so one population one
model play and analyze why do they need
to work in your world in the real time
they need usually they have tasks to
prepare this optimal price during one
working day so they need to do a lot of
adjustments and usually this reference
sample is different from the sample they
are working on so they analyze and
analyze and analyze and they need to
build very fast they need to build
predicate models very very fast
otherwise they will be concentrated on
building models not on assessing quality
of the results not on delivering the
recommendation to the decision-maker the
second approach under one hour if you
build a predictive model usually you'd
like to know what's potential of your
data what what predictive power could
you squeeze out of this data so you
apply an automatic method and run and
see usually need to have something like
an upper benchmark and lower benchmark
to see what you could achieve using a
pretty complicated model and what could
you achieve using a simple model so in
these situations modelers need to build
a model pretty fast but not in a real
time the third one is a couple of hours
when you know that data quality is okay
you don't have false predictors you
build a couple of almost final models
you should to be able to do to build
them during one working day and the last
approach is to build a final model this
one that will be deployed and it may
take a couple of days but it's good to
start building this model after working
day for example 4 p.m.
sixteen hours and have the model built
on the next day so you have very
different tasks in terms of time and use
it of these models and you could think
why don't use just brute force and more
computing power so for some of you it
may be strange but what I know from my
experience with corporate environment
it's not obvious so usually you cannot
use cloud computing even if you have
anonymized data and buying even a laptop
can take form answers what next using
Linux maybe just not possible have you
have you heard about such situations
okay I I can see some people are nodding
they have corporate experience but some
people just are just looking at me
but believe me let's throw in very big
companies and what was maybe maybe funny
maybe sad for us making predictive
modeling fitting of predictive models on
powerful machines in parallel what was
not an easy task so we had a very
powerful computer really very powerful
and to make this model preparing the
software to build this model in parallel
in a way that it uses full computing
power was a hard task a really hard task
so that's all I wanted to say as an
introduction next it's time for Tomic
come back to the floor take the floor so
I'm going I'm going to show you one way
to speed up the process so that you can
pretty much jump from one of those speed
of analytics into the lower lower
into the lower bracket we've pretty much
not that man not that man additional
code so how do you usually choose hyper
parameters in a typical analytical tasks
well there are some defaults usually the
defaults are usually not that good for
our particular tasks we can take some
advice from internet for example if
someone if we observe that our neural
network stops learning we often see
advice on the internet to adult learning
right and upwards downwards whatever
whatever the suggestor thinks it will be
okay who heard who has heard of a grad
student optimization this is a running
joke in some circles you make a grad
student optimization by hiring a bunch
of grad students and asking them to pick
the hyper parameters for you the one who
picks the best publishes a paper so they
have an incentive experts from
experience well usually we do analytics
many different many similar problems one
after another so we can't to some degree
reuse a hyper parameter from one task to
another we can't play with manual tuning
bothersome there are some standard
approaches like grid search random
search and there's model optimization
model based optimization so let's start
from the basics what what is supervised
learning this is well this is just an
intuition it doesn't have to be perfect
definition we want to have built a
predictive model for some relations so
we we have we want to build a model
between x and y for example and of
course we want the model to make as
little mistakes
as as possible so we introduced some
measure of how good the model is how how
many errors does it does it make and we
compare different hyper parameters by
comparing the errors that are generated
by those hyper parameters but there are
many many possible hyper parameters
usually and trying all of all of the
combinations may be just might just take
too much time so well we could try
predicting what will be the error if we
choose hyper Papa this set of hyper
parameters or that set of hyper
parameters and I don't know if it's just
me but I see similarities between the
first line and the fourth line it just
be because we can actually use Selma
supervised learning to learn the mapping
between hyper parameters and the errors
and this is the idea behind model-based
hyperparameters optimization so the
algorithm rough sketch is let's say we
already have some hyper parameters and
their error estimates they don't have to
be too many of them
a bunch of them will be nice we built a
model that predicts error from the hyper
Pramod parameters then we pick we
observe the model analyze it look for
some new hyper parameters which the
model says that would be better than the
current ones actually tried that model
out of a problem probably a bunch of
other hyper parameter sets and add the
new result to the learning set so that
we can retrain again the model that
predicts our errors is it simple
so the questions why is it why is it
well it isn't that simple how to get
first examples well we have to have
Sammy and some initial learning set
usually I just pick a few hyper
parameters at random train get some
initial estimates we want to use
supervised learning to make supervised
learning so we have to decide on hyper
parameters of the second side in a hyper
of the second model and again there are
some trusted choices one trusted choice
is Gaussian processes also called
rigging if you know what if you did some
geo statistics or something like that
clicking is a popular method there
Gaussian processes and work on a quite
well if you have the hyper parameters
that are just not maracle if you have
factors or you know if you have let's
say integers there are some other
methods that are also trusted like to
have personal estimators but usually you
pick some simple matters because you
don't have too many data too much data
if you have if you will train for
example 200 models 200 sets of
parameters that's probably the most you
can expect to to get during a working
day for example so this motors won't be
one bit at large
okay let's say we have we already have
some supervised model that predicts
errors how do you pick new hyper
parameters again you idea is to just
sample the model at random from the
whole space of hyper parameters let's
say use the model to predict 1000 hyper
parameter sets and pick the one that
scores the best and the last question
here is sequential only you can see that
the process looks a pretty much
sequential so that interior you you
could all only test one model at a time
in practice you can actually sample from
the model multiple hyper parameter sets
and to paralyze it however it's a
trade-off because you spend more
computers no time but the sample type of
parameters are from weaker predictive
model so they might be not as well
estimated as they could be in a
sequential model so it's a trade-off so
do I have to code it by myself
fortunately not there are several
libraries that are doing this pretty
much from out of the box so there is a
spearmint which is this one was one of
the first I had off to discussion
processes plus lots of tweaking site so
that it works better for hyper parameter
selection for example to house the input
and inputs based again on the model so
it can fit the errors much better than
just plain Gaussian process hyper opt is
my current favorite in in the Python
world it also for example to denote that
some hyper parameters should be
estimated separately
if some major parameter changes for
example in extra boost it is usually
suggested to attune gamma for each max
def separately and in hyper ops you can
specify that in the our world there is
an ml RMB Oh which is separating you by
library but ours is quite solid
there are lots and lots of other tools
Smokey's I think in Java noise I think
in MATLAB
I'm sure under a cloud based systems are
available so these systems are pretty
much you define the tasks they send you
a set of hyper parameters to test you
send them the error rate and they again
send you another hyper promoter set test
so that you don't have to set up even
the Machine dorito to analyze the data
I've used one of them it was quite good
experience so some codes do you know as
scikit-learn you probably know given
that this is a patent conference usually
instead of this line you have a
definition of a specific model like easy
boost or SVM etc hyperope comes with
[Music]
very easy-to-use wrapper that actually
just tries several models at once you
don't even have to specify what are the
spinner parameters to optimize it comes
with the right defaults and these four
lines are pretty much everything you
need to do to have a simple model based
optimization so not exactly rocket
science right this is how you can
actually specify more of the task for
example here I decided to try a random
forests and K enhance only
and ask the hyperope to also use PCA as
a property except optionally and it will
also tune all the necessary hyper
parameters inside random forests or
Canaan in a Millar MBO actually the only
difference between not using MBO and
using model based optimization is this
line the last line you had this like a
last line and you get all the tuning
using MBO instead of let's say research
or random search how does it work well I
I got a small case study some hard
drives from some storage company back
base if you if you know they have lots
of dry sand would like to know when they
fail so I did ten runs of random search
on this data set ten runs of model based
of optimization and four random search I
got a picture like this how to interpret
it this is how good the model became
after this many iterations so for
example to get to this part of the graph
II you needed to have between 10 and 180
probably iterations depending on how
lucky was the random search so in
general the lower the better and for
comparison MBO gets this way so pretty
much
ambu got it quite right go to the end of
the scale in five times or ten times
less iterations than using random search
this is not an unusual result however
it's still better than what I usually
observe I don't know actually why this
happened so well but you can expect the
results like that too
this method has some drawbacks
building the surgery and surgery model
of errors next time if it's three of
persons estimators it's usually not not
much time if it's gotten processes well
if you think as VN slow Gaussian
processes are more than even more slow
slower less of this polarization think I
can talked about introduces additional
complexity in terminal building if you
do just a grid search it's simple it's
if you do rendom set it's simple to
understand this is less simple doesn't
work too well with too many have hyper
parameters but actually no method works
twelve too many hyper parameters as long
as you do a gradient class optimization
there are no and no golden ballots for
simple data sets maybe not worth the
effort if you have such simple data set
you don't actually need to tune imagine
many have hyper parameters you can
usually do it manually and it will be
fine
benefits you can search bigger bigger
spaces because the method is faster
saves time and enables hyper permit
introspection this is from a different
project this is from a different project
I did two years ago I had several high
parameters of which two are presented
here and this was done using Gaussian
processes so you I could actually
estimate how unsure was the model about
the errors for those hyper parameters
and this is how it's how the hyper
parameters were should it about the
place where the hyper parameters were
very good we're often then tested to
check new possibilities the places where
there were no not many actually good
hyper parameters then will automatically
ignored so that it didn't spend time to
test them
and there are some popular common
extension of this ideas you can search
hyper parameters not just by picking
them at random but by looking for
expected improvement and as far as I
know this is implemented in MLR MBO you
can actually try to make the model
optimized expected improvement per
second so include the dead time it takes
to train a model into the estimate so
that for example if we know that this
model would be will take more time more
troublesome hyper parameters compute it
would test it rarely include uncertainty
in gases this is what I shot in the
picture in iterative models like neural
networks of boosting you can actually
try doing this after every iteration
step for example Efrain after every perk
and get even better results and with
some some models you can actually change
hyper parameters during the learning for
example in neural networks some
regularization parameters or learning
rate and adjust them also using an
ambien model-based optimization I've
seen some very nice papers that were
showing that I haven't seen actually a
code that would do it automatically but
I think this will show up in the next
year or two and back to the business
impact if we can skip a time necessary
to just compute models that are weak we
can upgrade our models for example use
the models that we would usually use for
longer estimates for real-time analytics
which means that we save lots of time of
an ID of people who do analytics and
this time is expensive right so using
good tools and hyper parameter
optimization is a good tool it's useful
not just in business actually I did it
in science and it was even better I
think thank you very much do you have
any questions to our planets is there
any way to insert like human knowledge
inside high parameter okay I can give an
example of this because because let's
say the data the data set doesn't have
complex complex interactions so you know
that let's say you don't have you don't
need very deep very deep trees you can
just tell the model to for example test
them less or put some priors on the
hyper parameter space in Gaussian
processes this is easy in tree of person
estimators you can also put some
probabilities on the initial space this
is a very nice idea
have you tried combining this technique
with stacking models but you are planto
you see something like you think that
this is a good idea or not
so there are two with
[Music]
so from your from your experience how
good is this method in avoiding local
minima in this hyperspace
okay and have you heard about particle
swarm optimization
okay thank you okay it's the 100
questions so thank you very much
[Applause]